in an electronic world where a few Taps
on a device keyboard sends an invitation
or greeting card it's not all that
common anymore to receive something
printed the oldfashioned way yet there's
nothing quite as elegant as the crisp
recessed print that traditional letter
Press Printing
produces letter Press Printing is a
centuries old method that's making a
comeback the printing press makes an
impression in the paper with raised type
as it applies the ink
the printer first sketches out some
design
ideas then he detours into digital
technology finalizing the colors and
composition and choosing the font in
traditional metal
type he cuts paper to the size of the
greeting card he's making the paper is
100% cotton which is more pliable than
standard wood fiber paper thus enabling
a deeper impression cotton paper is more
delicate so he has to cushion it while
cutting otherwise the clamp holding the
stack would Dent the
paper now it's time to set up he locates
the selected font in the type
cabinet each individual character called
a sort is backwards because backwards
type prints
forwards he finds the sorts for the
first line of text and lines them up
left to right and upside down in what's
called a composing stick
once he completes the type of the line
called a form he clamps it in
[Music]
position then he takes a metal frame
called a Chase and mounts the form at a
specific position inside the frame
filling the excess space with blocks of
wood called
[Music]
Furniture just below the piece of
furniture that's underneath the form he
places a compression device called a
coin and and expands it with a key this
locks the form in
position he chooses each ink color from
a fan deck then follows the recipe to
mix
it this is color extender which works
like paint thinner diluting a dark color
to a lighter
shade he mixes the color extender into
the ink blending the two ingredients
thoroughly
when the color matches the fan deck
sample he places a glob on a piece of
cardboard and takes the mixture over to
the printing
press he applies it in dots all over the
ink
[Music]
disc then he pumps on the tdle to run
the rollers back and forth across the
disc this spreads the ink over the disc
and onto the
rollers he inserts the chase containing
the form at to What's called the bed of
the
press now for the test run the printer
pulls the lever to bring the bed and
platin together so that the form Inked
by the rollers creates an ink filled
impression in the
paper if the print is off a bit he marks
the correct position by
pencil and installs gauge pin which will
hold the paper
[Music]
there now he's ready to start printing
there's no automation here he manually
places one sheet at a time in the gauge
pin the ink drives quickly because it's
rubber based and because cotton paper
absorbs
well this printer's technique is a
hybrid of traditional and modern
approaches as he uses computer generated
Graphics he sends the digital file to a
company that makes a polymer printing
plate which he mounts on an aluminum
base that fits in the chase of the press
he switches plates to do the next
graphic in a different color layered
over the
[Music]
first the polymer plates marry the old
and new technology by making it possible
to print computer generated Graphics by
traditional letter
[Music]
press after printing the inside of this
green reading card as well he uses a
scoring rule mounted in another press to
make a perfectly straight fold line down
the middle of the
[Music]
paper the result is beautiful textured
print on elegant cotton paper just like
the good old days before inkjets e-cards
and evites bamboo ceramic lights Add A
Touch of Zen to any space make native
ceramic and inspired by bamboo they
resemble bundles of tropical grasses but
they're not exact replications these
light fixtures offer an artistic
interpretation of an exotic element from
the natural
[Music]
world trying to create a tropical
Ambiance it's all in the lighting these
ceramic lights celebrate the natural
beauty of bamboo and set the
mood making the ceramic casing starts
with a slurry of clay and water known as
slip a propeller mixer evenly
distributes the particles the slip flows
through a hose and into plaster molds
The Artisan controls the amount going in
ensuring that each one is filled just
below the brim over 3 hours the clay
thickens and congeals along the edges
after pouring out the remaining slip he
trims the clay casting which has a
putty-like consistency
after leaving it to solidify a bit more
he carefully disassembles the mold
revealing the clay casting with a bamboo
like
detail after curing overnight the
casting further solidifies and the color
lightens using a knife he adds more
definition to some of the detail and
cleans up the rough
edges he also shaves off protrusions
formed where the mold Parts came
together he lightly Sands the entire
bamboo ceramic casting to smooth over
any remaining
imperfections using a wet sea sponge he
washes the entire
casting this softens the clay on the
surface and gets rid of any minute
scratches left by the the
sanding The Artisan then Cuts holes in
the back of the casting one is for
installing the light socket and the
other is to run wires to the electrical
junction
box with a clay surface still moist he
carves nodes or joints into the bamboo
canes he also Cuts wide vertical lines
to create the effect of cracks that
occur in bamboo naturally when they dry
out after firing the clay casting in a
Kil and then cooling it overnight the
material has become a strong durable
piece of ceramic this crafts person
examines it for imperfections and then
Begins the painting
process she sprays a very light yellow
paint onto the bamboo ceramic this gives
the piece just a hint of color but it
provides the desired
undertone
next she mixes a green oil paint with
thinner and then brushes the mix into
the grooves and notches this accentuates
these
areas she also brushes it onto the edges
of the bamboo ceramic light box to
better Define the
profile using a soft cotton cloth she
blots up some paint from the pallet and
wipes it on the ceramic this softens the
brush strokes and gives the ceramic cane
structure a hint of
green she sets the light casing on a
revolving stand and inspects the
coverage she then applies a liberal
amount of brown paint to the entire
piece and the brown color completely
overpowers the green and yellow
paints she rubs off a lot of the brown
paint this tones a it down and subtly
brings out the other colors this
produces color variations that evoke the
different tones of dried
bamboo the paint transforms the
piece a technician inserts the socket
and pulls the wires through one of the
holes and out the
back he secures the socket in the light
box from the back with a washer and
nut and that completes this bamboo
ceramic light
fixture making it takes roughly 1 week
but the final result is very
unique while providing illumination it
may also be an object of
conversation